fühlen sie sich bereit den rosenstein
ist zum loslaufen eines fordert business
das sind 4 geschichte grunde mancher wo
sich aus proben tür nachfolgt
eine von der eine ist martinstag
[Musik]
wir haben alles gute jahr nach langer
suche danach folgt die praxis gefunden
ich habe schon gesagt die kulisse ist ja
fast so schön wie in der praxis freud
und leid meint hergiswil und augen
andere wurde nachfolger zu beteiligen
sie sind im moment die situation noch
gar nicht ganz realisieren das ist eine
spannende situation war bisher noch
nicht in so einer situation hier mit so
wichtigen persönlichkeiten an einem so
schönen ort zu einer praxisübernahme
aber ich denke die nächsten tage welches
realisieren und das wird sich setzen und
ich bin gespannt
danke
es bleibt noch eine freude für jahr lang
hätte martin sieg auf den moment
gewartet
hervorragend war gar nicht wissen es mir
so viel besser geht als am morgen
für ein so relaxt und entspannt und gut
das schon
ja danke
beruhigend wenn man weiß noch mehr als
530 oder martin sieg mit 7-zip rosenhof
im ammertal in röthenbach stadt bis wir
uns erst große hochzeit bevor
salome oder hund unterstützung vor dem
vater schon nach der krassen events mit
hey was ja noch viel harte arbeit aus
oder brauchen wir dieses haus das sie
250 ps oder 318 i
die tom und salome sind knappe halbe
jahr absitzen vor dem hof röthenbach -
wirtschaftsbetrieb mit 14 zusätzlich
setzen sie auf agrotourismus und unserem
label wir landleben es fliesst
unternehmen aufbaut es ist mir immer
noch leben sagen wir's mal gemacht ich
habe aber besetzt kfz gut sind wir sehr
gut die aufforderung für das nicht lange
da sie mit peter und andreas mitbewohner
von betreute wohnen wo sie halbiert die
150 sitzen kompetenz die politik mit den
lehrern richters eine große terrasse
dass mir das projekt flachen bürger
machen
[Musik]
unterwegs mit drin
aber bis heute ist die anlage 2 zu ihren
aufgaben gehört karten wirklich
unterwiesen
und alkohol sticker auf
guttenberg ist historische museum war
waren münster vorgeführt
am 22
wer legt sich ob sie den achten sieg
wartet und länger als frühere buch
vorgestellt ist sicher so sehr
methodisch kaum erklangen ort hätten
angst macht weil sie das hexe die
wirklich recht ähnlich kommerzielle
quito und ja ich glaub ich überhaupt
nicht nach hause
für die leadvocals schlimmste lavastrom
ab und verlängert
collins oft biblische thema aktuell auf
mit der schulreform volk israel aus
ägypten behandelt und sucht jetzt im
historischen museums bayern eine
umstellung zu ägypten und zum thema
flucht
[Musik]
die velofahrerin sind nennt die
institute peter christ vorgänger vor der
allen 27 jahre lang war mit leib und
seele und sieht vorstände jahren
funktioniert und west
ez new aufgefunden er war zwei tage pro
monat taxi für menschen mit behinderung
das ist glaube nicht hatte der stärkste
motor kam zusammen
das metas einfach befriedigend
und das ist hört dass die geschädigten
von kansas creek sechs oscars stimmt
ricky gar nicht so komplett verdecken er
nach vorn machen meint betreuten nach
wie vor die bildung im computerbereich
es ist wahnsinnig sexy und das hat nicht
nutzen und natürlich so langsam das coni
hat centers wo ein wille nicht schon
morgen wisse was auf dem moment
begeistert ich mit dem ich liege ja
korrekt und hätten sie es nicht die
möglichkeit das nicht aus vor vor dies
hinge zone handke
das macht es ja gewohnt schöner grüner
zu machen
[Musik]
marcelo woche
offiziell übernimmt der praxis erstellt
bis dahin ist ja noch gestellt und wird
vom markt in seehausen nachfolger der
patienten vorgestellt
der plötzliche vorstellen hallo hoffe du
hast gut mit ihm kraft finden euch das
vorstellen der stadt schicken
und das hast du wieder zum anderen soll
das die 3 bis mitte juli ein riesiges
gefüllt mit
das muss sehr vielversprechend und
dramatiker bisher obwohl ist ganz frisch
sind sind sehr gut mit dem schon eine
schnelle vorstellen im opern- und
kollege schoss zurück schreibt also sich
erfreut dass es mich begeistert als sich
sehr gut auch kein cent aus dem badisch
schild worden hätte geschrieben
das ist gut für dich für ihn und auch
für uns und er kann man sagen dass die
schmerzen seit drei wochen zu nehmen
sind
der marcel wolter und außer der ärzte
familie in hamburg
vor drei wochen haben sie da den großen
zeh angeschlagen
ja dann sollten wir das auch
sicherheitshalber
das vor ort für innere medizin hätte der
versicherungs bild in der schweiz
absolviert und zwei jahre lang in einer
gruppenpraxis trient super also die
ersten tage sind natürlich spannend und
ich habe das gefühl dass es wirklich ein
sehr schöner start war ich bin sehr
herzlich begrüßt worden habe eine schöne
blume zu beginn bekommen und wir haben
gemeinsam gemütlich dann auch schon das
was vergessen gehabt und es waren sehr
schöne stadt ja jetzt krank ein bisschen
hektisch tatsächlich ja genau weil
mehrere patienten gleichzeitig
willkommen sind aber die damen
organisieren das normalerweise sehr gut
und die patienten sind auch
verständnisvolle und dem ortsteil die
der nächste männer dort mit martin sieg
erschöpft an mit ihm zweimal so dass es
so begabt war leistet ist ihre meinung
dazu
erst seit ein paar tagen elisa
zunehmende spannung
die frage ist halt und drehende tropfen
muss halt auch angenommen hat ist
vielleicht nicht
es ist eine von tieferen kursen politik
dieses kleine paradies will die beine
hinter und da ist muss erzählt voß krise
relativ klingen bevor die
entzündungswerte weiter steigen sich
danach selbst wirklich entwickelt ja
verschieden snb die von schumacher um
2010 genommen
spezifische und und dann muss ihnen dass
das kombinierte gut laufen die praxis
mit über 50 patienten in zukunft zur
zusätzlichen arzt wohin entlastet also
ich bin gespannt ich wie gesagt das ist
ein abenteuer für mich auch ich kann
jetzt noch gar nicht ab schon was alles
auf mich zukommt ich weiß dass es
wirklich viel organisation ist und ein
gewisses organisationstalent dazu gehört
aber ja ich bin ja optimistisch und
schaut einfach mal wie es kommt ich
hoffe schröter bach macht salome und tom
alles parat für die erst groß hochzieht
[Musik]
christian träsch sind ist aber
auszugehen
über 30 jahre lang wenn sie hier bolt
wieso man gesundheitlich immer
schlechter gegangen ist die müssen
verkaufen
transnet hat die heime werden schafe
treppe die russlands
bis jetzt gut gemacht
[Musik]
heute vormittag die frage der woche
das macht ihnen kann man eigentlich
wollte sie ja man muss mit der caritas
warnt er jene trifft gejagt wurde in
zusammenhang mit dem bau beschäftigt mit
dem volk israel wahrscheinlich mit der
bibel die historische museumsbahn wo
darlehen sind kultur für ägypten bringen
48 alle sachen die mir da setzte im
echten wichtig ist vielleicht wenn wir
uns jetzt darauf herum sammeln
das ist das kind da wäre der nase und
mund bereich mit den zähnen holen
röthenbach sind die ersten gäste und
transport offen
ich sage mir auszügen jetzt damit läuft
das ist aber jene noch was man in brehna
ist aber hier ist wirklich traurig
findet auf der bühne stoppt hochzeiten
und events sind momentan
haupteinnahmequelle von twitter
[Musik]
nein
ist
[Musik]
wenig alles frisch vom eigenen hof und
aus der region
[Musik]
ja
der umzug vom israelischen volkes
ägypten flucht sie in absprache mit
vielen gemeint und historische museum
baden italien beschlossen mit dem kind
wanderausstellung flucht das thema mit
aktueller bilder geschaffen wird
[Musik]
es ist dass sie die nachrichtenlage
lasse mit den eltern ab dass es
vielleicht doch wieder zusammen liefert
als ich mein geschockt war heute morgen
ist die parole oma warum haben die
flüchtlinge überhaupt aber um die
bildung eines ordners tallinn wichtig
dass sie das was sie gesehen kann man
mit dem kind bespricht
aus erzählte dass er glaubt fragt ob es
überhaupt aufs 80 kameras dokumentieren
das ist ja schon mit wird nicht haye und
dass meine vielleicht hilft genau das
mag selbst was del potro wir müssen
genauso für uns nicht so schlimm wie wir
es verstanden ist hoffe die flüchtlinge
wonach eine firma dass das wird dann
gerade die welt ist das schöne land
rover knall sondern dass die bürger das
ist schwierig und sicherheit suchen
also ja ja ja
[Musik]
am hus arzt martin seelisches immer sei
liege sie dass es nachfolger patienten
der heime oder im alters und pflegeheim
besucht und vor allem der mensch und
seine geschichte mittelpunkt stellt das
sieht eine frau - gesagt sie mit
bedingungen
wir sind frisch 35 davon mit manchmal
jahrzehnte in der praxis treu geblieben
so fort ja tatsächlich diese woche schon
angefangen und ich habe das glück dass
ich mit doktor sieg noch
zusammenarbeiten
eine weile bis es dann halt passt dann
muss ich denn machen
jörg nießen sie frei zeuge geladen
dass sie gerne gegangen
aber ihr könnt natürlich aber ich habe
so eine gute job gehabt dass eben nie
geld gegangen bin also ihr geld ein nein
aber das gar nicht vorstellen doch sind
das ist ja andere berufe eine strenge
werden und dann dass sie und sowieso auf
170 ländern werden indem sie ja dann ist
der zusammenhang ebenso ja gespannt
ich weiß gar nicht darf man als arzt so
was im herbst so kleinigkeiten die für
sie
wechselt ein heft ventus was der prozent
bedeutet für viele selbstverständlich
oder wird da brennt licht operiert und
wo man gerade frauen bei gehört der
treppe wechsel macht oder wenn kinder
bis schweiz passiert die stellen denkt
man eigentlich ständig oder wenn sie
bestand ende so auch danke show
abliefern
das ist die lage laut facto zu einem
sich gerät fahren
es ist so ein bisschen auch ins kalte
wasser springen weil man kann ja vorher
nicht wissen wie es wird trotzdem macht
das ja auch gerade interessant weil man
dann ja sicherlich jeden tag neue dinge
erleben wird und viele neue gesichter
kennen lernt und die situation an zu
haben wo man endlich wo angekommen ist
ist eine ganz neue dimension
aber ich glaube es ist halt auch gut im
leben mal einen ort zu finden wo man
dann auch bleiben kann wo man sich
wohlfühlen kann
und da gibt es da gibt es wahrscheinlich
auch schlechtere orte auf der welt als
die ehec ist wieder am see wo man
wo die entscheidung leicht fällt zu
bleiben der markt in sieg schaffen nur
so lange in der praxis bis marcelo
wolken zusätzlichen arzt gefunden hat
[Musik]
jetzt auf dem hof bis wlans ist ein
erfolg sie sind auch auf ihrem bauernhof
und verbindet traditionelle bohrer mit
ihren ideen vom agrotourismus und mit
ihnen gemeinsam mit
[Musik]
die hände gut geklappt jetzt eben dieses
gefühl mich sicher viel möglich dank
riesch an der kasse machen
letzter bewohner integration verhindert
dass ich jetzt richtig nett zuständige
ihre rolle gefunden
[Musik]
als frau pfarrerin mit dem freund jan
drees krems ist sehr und nummer drei
nach und klar so ganz ist nicht so
schwierig sehr aber ich glaube sie dass
mit ostermundiger damit der
agglomerationsgemeinde glaubt ihm nach
linie durch lieber das wirklich alles
die situation verbessere und eigentlich
sagen es ist auch sie hatte sie in
gantikow fertigung war schon häufig
macht du kommst aber das ist ja
plötzlich wie nichts machen ich glaube
es sei gottes ja dass sie weiter mit dem
becher sachliches offener und nicht auf
menschen zugehen da aber immer noch als
sie arbeitet aber das freute sich dass
da wieder schon offene person ist
[Musik]
und wie xsp markus im comeback platte
mit spezielle heimlicher spezielle
kundschaft
ja es ist im moment nicht konkret
konkret dass sie versorgten die pics i
und ii 40 meter wenig grip die zwei war
da bis auf buchhaltungs ist gold und
egalisiert bitte 40 axxio eine havanna
interessant machen
mit mit blind von instruktoren vorfall
hab grad der rückseite das geht nicht
das nicht machen
oder hättet jetzt cupertino der kante
mit mit seiner prof
und so geht's einfach nicht ihr wollt
einfach hochladen oder so übernimmt der
freude trauer das weiterführt und da
ganz kundenstamm über das los zu
empfangen am morgen ruft das comeback
ist für markus mehr als er lade mit
hamlin die situation es ist ein teil von
sieben vertreter als und ziemlich 100
compact nicht der fall
einige das ist nur eines sorgen
das ist der ist schon erreicht
wenn sie aber bis bedeutet dass das
hochintegrierte deshalb mit 11 8 bezwang
hat dass man das halt machen
hornes kräftiges orange machte sony
papiere 26 jahren
da hiermit möglich wenn man nämlich zehn
paaren und land dass die fluglinie
detail hier den und und erkennt handle
da gelte teilstück gehabt also längerem
erwartet auch noch richtig bisher wenig
bezahlt statt tee oder wasser und
verdammt wenn das richtig gut ich hatte
es nach wie vor dass sogar nur mäßiges
comeback wenn du markus sch
mit roma dass das auf robben nimmt das
war ein metronom frau was wäre für das
die hat er sicher noch besser da bin ich
überzeugt mit ihrem schalen nach die
männer das bedienen
seriös natürlich hat er aber dass das
[Musik]
passiert sie haben wir ganz sicher
irgendeine steht zum loslegen einig vor
der business das sind wir geschichte sie
für manche wo sich aus orden tür
nachfolgte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die schmecken
[Musik]
in der schweiz glück